ce soir vous visité avec nous les usines
de la société française des métaux debré
250 employés y fabrique on an mal an un
million au moins d'ustensiles de cuisine
en aluminium en cuivre or rose ou chromé
le grand prêtre de cette alchimie
moderne il berges elle
présente son entreprise
la société française des métaux ouvrés
dont le sigle est le trèfle a été créée
en 1904 à mons et dans le doubs pour y
faire essentiellement des articles de
balance riz et d'orfèvrerie en cuivre
aux alentours de 1914 créer une toute
nouvelle gamme en étant les premiers en
france à mettre au monde en quelque
sorte des articles en aluminium
culinaire nous avons travaillé
assez longtemps à mons et puis nous
sommes venus nous implanter à vesoul
heures
il faut voir les 7000 m² de locaux le
parc impressionnant de machines il faut
suivre toute la chaîne de fabrication
pour saisir le chemin parcouru depuis
l'époque du petit atelier vésulien
l'on fabriquait alors des objets de
toilette et même la baignoire en or du
tsar de russie
il faut voir toutes les presses à
emboutir les disques d'aluminium les
machines à laver et à dégraisser
il faut aussi admirer leur pousseur qui
donne un galbe au métal informe pour en
faire un élégant récipient
seul endroit où la machine n'a pas
encore pu remplacer la prodigieuse
habiletés de l'homme la fonderie
le métier de fondeur se perd de plus en
plus du moins il le pari est ce que
c'est vrai ça c'est assez pénible parce
que l'hiver ça va mais là les idées on
endure la chaleur quand même vous avez
qu'à l'aller les 53 ans et vous le
faites depuis la plage ça fait trente
ans je suis à l'usiné plus rondes
toujours fondeur de la presse mais je
n'ai appris ici avec les anciens qui
m'ont appris comment ça va prend tous
les jours en apprentissage ou sur
l'apprentissage c'est une immense en
apprend tous les jours en travaillant
sur les eaux et la peine vous voulez
dire que vous venez de plus en plus
habiles plus à une prix plus habiles les
premiers temps maintenant et 5 en trois
ans peut-être que d'ici faire la nique
ça va peut-être plancher un ip alors que
tu fous rires sont une robe est chargé
mais toujours à fermer moyenne 6 au lieu
de gagner mais ton 439 en rien que 350
je me contenterai ici ça vous fait rien
par mois en moyenne aux 70 75 est ce que
c'est un métier qui peut attirer les
jeunes à les jeunes et jeunes courageux
et oui peut-être voilà je vous demande
un conseil vous avez un fils qu'est ce
que vous lui conseiller de faire pas
fondeur
dernière phase spectaculaire le
traitement des cuivres avant l'étamage
chaque cuivre passe dans dix-huit ben
recuit virage nick l'âge et enfin
chromage il en sort satiné et brillant
des mains féminines vont alors
lamballe et
j'aimerais qu'on parle de travail vous
êtes là debout toute la journée à oui
moi je suis toute la journée deux jours
enfora c'est le soir où les pratiques et
s'envoler dans les airs comme on dit ça
va mais une fois que je rentre à la
maison je sens que je suis fatigué qu'on
peut savoir si ce n'est pas officiel
combien vous gagnez
ça n'est pas une nombreux heurts
peut-être un début c'est quand même pas
ce que vous pouvez nous situer
l'importance de votre entreprise sur le
plan national nous sommes parmi les
quatre plus gros fabricant d'aluminium
et en ce qui concerne les articles
purement ménages et exclut les articles
d'hôtellerie nous avons la deuxième
place